[Music]
even to this day
we continue to follow the music we work
with the most famous drummers in the
world to make the sounds that they need
so they can make music
my name is paul francis and i'm a symbol
maker for the average zelda symbol
company
symbol making has remained the same for
almost 400 years
zildjian symbol goes back to 1623
we're part of this
legacy of cymbal making and it's really
really exciting that we're continuing
this history
we make well over 600 models in
different diameters
and it's much like if you're a carpenter
you don't have one tool you have a
toolbox full of tools so as a drummer
the symbols are part of your toolbox
okay you have a big symbol like this
that's called a ride somebody keep time
on these are high hats and these are two
symbols that come together then you have
crash symbols and these all offer
different sound colors so the drummer
can express himself in a non-verbal way
within the context of a piece of music
symbol making is a lot like being a
blacksmith or a farrier there's a lot of
steps that go into making a symbol and
you know it can take a couple days
we're gonna take that casting we're
gonna throw it in an oven
then we're gonna shape it
we're gonna hammer it
we're gonna shave it we're gonna lathe
it
goes down to a simple tester he plays it
sound quality cosmetic quality we look
for it all
[Music]
i've had the privilege to work with a
lot of great drummers steve gad
elvin jones
zack starkey who is actually ringo
starr's son zach plays in the who in a
variety of other bands and part of
beaufort carter beaufort plays for the
dave matthews
the list goes on and on
i've been here for 30 years it's really
fantastic that i'm actually part of the
world of music and music that's going to
be created or has been created and it's
my job
right now to make sure that that my
knowledge gets passed on to the next
people that are going to continue it for
the next 400 years
[Music]
you